in a city of six million people life
goes on because it has to but don't
underestimate the pressure that these
people are under particularly in the
south of the city and the east where we
are now where we're closest to the the
rebel front lines there are only about
half a mile to a mile away from us here
and that means the occasional rocket
comes over and lands there's a little
pockets of damage that we can see that's
a pressure on the people here as well
and bear in mind that what they've heard
from the international media is that the
American plan is to facilitate the
advance of this rebel army perhaps even
give it access into Damascus and as they
understand it here this rebel army isn't
made up of Syrians it's made up of
foreigners jordanians saudis Chechens
all kinds of professional jihadists who
mean them nothing but the worst kind of
terrorist was Al Qaeda Obama helping big
man you are really gas probably about
ninety-five percent of Americans are
completely against the war on Syria and
most of the world is but the American
government isn't listening to them I
think they should take more action and
just do the best they can to talk to
their government and tell them to stop
we thought you're filming his problem so
looking at him I'm filming spall
spontaneous demonstrations like that
that spring up on the streets a pretty
commonplace now just one example of the
kind of pressure that people in this
city are starting to feel now another
example of that are these seemingly
endless traffic jams all around Damascus
the army has thrown up checkpoints
everywhere it's really really starting
to affect people's lives I buddy another
example of a city that's changing up
until very recently it was forbidden by
law to sell anything on the streets here
in Damascus now the farmers are bringing
their stuff in from the fields and
selling them by the roadsides they're
making more money that way it's an
example of how the government is making
life a little easier for those that are
being hurt by the crisis and also it's a
sign that the government has more
serious things to worry about
as far as we know the last direct
communication between Damascus and
Washington was an open letter from here
the People's Assembly the Syrian
Parliament and attempt to persuade us
lawmakers to change the president's mind
indeed find common cause with the
Syrians and unite against their mutual
enemy al Qaeda the way things are going
of all the possible outcomes from this
ugly situation that is the least likely
of all